on échange et le feu avec ice de la
mission contre les terroristes de l'état
islamique c'est la chose caractère il a
dit aux canadiens qu'on n'était pas dans
une mission de combat c'était pour notre
mission terrestre en irak était tout
vice entre six autres ponctuée des
terroristes et j'ai dit c'est leur
mission nous sommes très fiers d'eux
pourquoi il a induit du canadien on ira
à une audience fixée au terrorisme oui
stephen harper hier aux communes qui
disait je sais que l'opposition trouve
terrible qu'on se tienne debout face aux
djihadistes il ajoutait que certains
d'entre eux se soient aussi quand tous
que l'opposition trouve terrible que
certains d'entre eux se soient fait tuer
par des militaires canadiens alors le
ton en voix du premier ministre a changé
cette semaine face aux critiques de
l'opposition sur la mission en irak
rentrée parlementaire ou rentrer
électorale à ottawa en tout cas beaucoup
de matière pour nos commentateurs ce
soir encore bonsoir à vous trois
donc la semaine dernière on parlait un
peu du thon caricatural à québec parce
que le pq avait parlé de l' influence de
l'arabie saoudite sur philippe couillard
aujourd'hui ce ton caricatural on
retrouve un peu à ottawa parce que steve
n'a pas le temps de caricaturer un peu
la position de l'opposition sur la
mission en irak daniel comment est-ce
qu'on peut interpréter ou comment est-ce
qu'il faut interpréter ce changement
tant de stephen a entre les mains
pardon une très bonne carte celle de la
fierté des canadiens de la peur des
canadiens aussi devant tout ce qui se
passe mais la fierté il va la jouer très
bien très fort d'autant plus que la
carte de l'économie est un peu plus pâle
à tout à l'heure à titre d'exemple sur
facebook le ministre james moore a placé
une magnifique photo de trois femmes
soldats kurdes combattants le groupe
etat islamique avec la mention au bas de
la photo il traduit littéralement le
canada est toujours du bon côté de
l'histoire
alors si vous dire où 120 stephen harper
il va jouer cette carte là à fond celle
de la sécurité celle de la fierté des
canadiens
le sondage aujourd'hui qui démontrait
que les deux tiers des canadiens l'appui
et sont prêts à lui pardonner des petits
et grands mensonges sur les détails de
la mission tâche à l'opposition pose des
questions si venant on peut répondre
vous n'êtes pas assez patriotique
qu'est ce que vous lisez dans ses propos
là je pense que daniel a dit bien c'est
vrai que on peut argumenter est ce que
les des soldats qui sont là sont dans le
feu du du combat ce qu'on a menti aux
canadiens mais est ce que les canadiens
vont se soucier de ça 2 du fait que le
premier ministre les a peut-être induit
en erreur je pense que probablement non
il faut le médecin en perspective ya
trois échanges de feu qui sont faits on
à 69 combattants sur le terrain c'est
pas énorme sont là depuis plusieurs mois
et je pense que le gouvernement essayait
d'être transparent avec ce qui s'est
passé parce qu'ils savent que dans deux
mois ils doivent revenir au parlement
est demandé est ce qu'on va étendre
cette mission parce que certainement ça
va pas être finie alors je pense jouer
la carte patriotique
c'est la meilleure façon pour le
gouvernement de faire que ce soit une
guerre ou une situation qui est appuyée
par la plus pop le canadien michel
comment est ce qu'il y six essais de
compét' quand même le rôle de
l'opposition
la présente pratiquement comme une
espèce de cinquième colonne qui sapent
les efforts du canada dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme
écoutez c'est aussi ridicule vous
mentionniez tantôt ce qu'on avait dit de
monsieur couillard la semaine dernière
la supposée influence de l'arabie sur sa
position sur la laïcité supposer que
monsieur walker des sympathies
jihadistes c'est aussi ridicule que ça
n'inquiète pas pour les djihadistes
s'inquiète pour la sécurité des soldats
canadiens qui sont en irak et je pense
qu'il y à des questions qui sont des
victimes
comment ça se fait que il ya seulement
les canadiens qui se font tirer dessus
que les autres membres de la coalition
ont semble-t-il ne sont pas dans cette
situation là je veux bien croire que les
canadiens sont bien d'accord pour que
nos soldats riposte mais il faudrait
d'abord savoir comment ça se fait qu'il
se trouve là alors qu'on leur avait dit
que c'est apple que daniel est ce qu'on
laissait un peu de dévier le liban passe
comme dit
il ya quand même des questions légitimes
sur le rôle et canadiennes et risque
qu'on leur fait courir le coût de cette
mission la durée oui il y en aurait ici
ce sont les questions très pertinentes
sauf que si vous connaissez bien s'ils
venaient à peu le respect du parlement
de la fonky du fonctionnement du
parlement des débats et cetera
démocratique c'est pas sa tasse de thé
il trouve qu'elle parlement c'est une
perte de temps ils le laissent entrevoir
de plus en plus mais avec semble demain
ce qui va aller annoncer à l'extérieur
du parlement de nouveaux projets doigts
et les députés qui vont connaître les
détails du projet doit devront se rendre
dans une salle quelque part alors que la
période de questions est en cours
alors comme respect du parlement vos
repas sain et sauf qu'un sévère peut se
dire un peu comme tâche n y êtes tout à
l'heure il fait le pari que les
canadiens vont voir le soir de façon
plus globale vont pas s'arrêter des
détails des contrats coûtent elles sont
attirées une fois ou deux fois ce que
des britanniques ont fait puis nous on
ne fait pas un hiver plutôt leur dire
écoutez il ya une crise majeure sur la
planète on envoie des soldats dans des
pays extrêmement dangereux comme l'irak
et la syrie
il faut vous attendre à ce qu'il reçoive
des coûts etc l'euro du canada d'être là
et de lutter contre le terrorisme
je vous vois réagir tâchant oui et ça
fait aussi venir un peu aussi sur ce que
michel a dit ça fait également les
affaires de l'aide [ __ ] également la
sphère des conservateurs si vous
rappeler car le band jacques comme on a
caricaturé jack layton qui voulait
négocier avec les talibans ça revient au
fait que ces prennent également passé
par la suite
c'est vrai c'est finalement passé mais
au moment qu'il a dit c'était très
controversée et sa polarise entre les
conservateurs et le npd le vote
pacifique avec le npd et le vote puis
militariste avec les conservateurs et ça
coince et libéraux au milieu ce que
monsieur harper et monsieur michael
c'est bien de faire cette élection qui
s'en vient et c'est probablement la
raison et c'est probablement la raison
que pour pour laquelle les libéraux 200
tentes qui vont probablement appuyer le
projet de loi demain pour pas avoir à
prendre position avant qu'on aille plus
loin je voudrais qu'on regarde ce que le
message du gouvernement est assez clair
j'aimerais qu'on écoute un extrait d'une
nouvelle vidéo que qui est sur son site
web le site du gouvernement
on va regarder ça on en parle du sud
après le gain des deux ne sera jamais
vaincu alors trois minutes de discours
patriotique sur la mission en et en irak
sur la menace terroriste avec une
musique appropriée je dirais tâche à
michel votre réaction à ce message
tellement claire est tellement
patriotique mais l'élection est lancée
insécure faire un coude
c'est c'est le message et je sais pas ce
qui me donnait le guichet qu'il était
aussi que l'on peut pas faire campagne
seulement sur l'économie il faut que les
conservateurs trouvent un autre chef
cheval de bataille et le patriotisme le
conflit militaire sol et ils savent que
c'est quelque chose qui tient à coeur
les canadiens les attentats qui ont eu
lieu à ottawa ont vraiment je pense
changer le ton de la menace terroriste
et je pense que c'est une situation et
que le gouvernement doit s'occuper de
cette question c'est parce qu'ils
doivent pas s'occuper de la menace
terroriste
mais ça ça les aide c'est certainement
vrai hockey table michel
évidemment c'est profiter avait coûté la
sécurité la loi l'homme c'est le fond de
commerce des conservateurs alors là
vraiment c'est le pactole ce qui se
passe actuellement pour eux la guerre en
irak les canadiens se font tirer dessus
la psychose du terroriste de façon
générale je voyais un sondage donne
aujourd'hui selon lequel quoi 2
deux canadiens sur trois considère que
le canada et est en guerre contre le
terrorisme notamment il ya aussi disons
une ligne à ne pas franchir il ya
presque autant de canadiens qui
craignent qu'on donne trop de pouvoir
aux agences de sécurité mais de façon
générale pour tout gouvernement
militariste si on veut une situation
comme celle-ci et tout et tout profit et
dans la mesure où comme mes deux
collègues faisaient l'économie va mal il
re peut-être plus mal on ne sait pas au
moment où l'élection sera déclenchée ça
fait un plan b superbe 9 de justin
trudeau daniel est ce que c'est c'est un
bon calcul pour lui d'appuyer ces
mesures antiterroristes - écoutez je
pense que oui parce que bon la cible des
conservateurs pendant cette campagne
électorale se sera pas thomas mulcair ça
va être justin trudeau
c'est justin trudeau qui les menace des
conservateurs souhaitent que thomas
mulcair reprendre reprennent du poil de
la bête enlève des votes aux libéraux
pour diviser le vote en leur faveur donc
leur cible c'est justin trudeau à partir
du moment où sur une question comme
celle là où ils l'ont vilipendé à
plusieurs reprises rappelez-vous
certaines déclarations trudeau sur les
chasseurs f-18 à conques ont considéré
comme des jouets à part ce moment autour
d'auch et de leur côté conservateurs
vont être un peu embêté vont devoir
trouver autre chose
bon j'aimerais qu'on dise un mot sur ce
premier débat du pq maintenant toujours
intéressant de voir des étudiants de
l'université de montréal à débat d'avant
match je dirais qu'ils nous préparent
pour la course à la direction qui peut
encore officiellement lancée alors
michel vous avez eu le plaisir d'y
assister qu'est ce que vous en avez
retenu surtout bien évidemment la mise
en scène était assez pittoresque disons
monsieur monsieur péladeau dans une
toute petite télévision depuis baie
comeau sur la scène ça faisait assez
assez spécial partageait pas dix ans
mais messieurs n'ont absolument pas mais
mais plus encore dans le cas de monsieur
péladeau ce qui m'a frappé c'est le peu
de degré de préparation qu'il avait ça
fait quand même plusieurs semaines que
monsieur péladeau
c'est qu'il voit le candidat sait qu'il
devra affronter ses adversaires dans des
débats celui ci était préparatoire mais
c'était quand même les bonnes questions
comme
c'est déjà être posée et il n'était pas
préparé à y répondre
tous les politiciens doivent vont
patiner un peu mais il ya des limites
et là monsieur péladeau était mais à des
années lumière des questions qui lui
étaient posées
je suis pas capable d'imaginer qu'il va
pouvoir continuer comme ça pendant des
semaines
faudra voir d'ailleurs combien de débats
il va y avoir et ça devient très
important je pense c'est une décision de
la direction du parti qui équivaut à
être lourde de conséquences si on n'est
pas le plus possible des débats monsieur
péladeau
c'est presque une forme de parti pris
michel poser la question daniel combien
de temps pourra-t-il encore faire
campagne comme ça sans peur sans
répondre aux questions
mon impression c'est que pierre karl
péladeau le vrai pierre karl péladeau
vers pas avant la fin de cette course et
la direction aux versements la journée
où il deviendra chef du parti québécois
parce que là ma tête ça fait pas
beaucoup de doute pour plusieurs raisons
cette course est la direction va se
faire sur les questions préférées du
parti québécois toutes les questions
d'identité la mécanique jeu référendum
tout ce qui a été reçu la dernière fois
par 75 % des québécois lors des
élections donc pierre karl péladeau va
surfer là dessus sur la question de la
souveraineté et détresse et c'est raide
et très convaincant
je pense qu'un an à 6 pour se rendre
jusqu'au congrès à la direction sur son
empire médiatique sur sa relation amour
haine avec les syndicats et surtout le
reste je pense pas qu'on va apprendre
beaucoup de pierre karl péladeau ça va
savoir enragés des autres candidats mais
si j'étais à la place de l ado c'est ce
que sera aussi que vous avez l'affût de
tout le parti que tous les gros canons
du pq sont prêts à avaler toutes sortes
de couleuvres pour qu'il gagne
vous avez pas besoin de faire beaucoup
d'efforts seul permettre la haine pour
les syndicats oui je vois pas l'amour
elle paraît qu'ils ont changé et
peut-être il va changer parce qu'il sait
exactement comme tu dis qu'il doit dire
certaines choses pour que pour rassurer
les militants péquistes qui sont pros
syndicaliste mais je pense que ça me
rappelle beaucoup la lutte de justin
trudeau et les libéraux le non lieu dont
on pourrait dire qu'il a fait la longue
campagne qu'il a fait il ya déjà que
rester dans la campagne jusqu'à la fin
mais on savait tous que c'était
c'était déjà décidé et lui aussi a fait
des gaffes mais le fait que sa
personnalité tellement important pour le
parti afek bon ils ont opté pour lui
monsieur péladeau je vois la même chose
qui arrive mais il ya quand même je
convoque monsieur péladeau a toutes les
chances de l'emporter mais dans une
course au leadership qui l'emporté c'est
évidemment le premier but mais ça doit
aussi servir à mobiliser une partie est
là il ya des éléments et je passe pas la
souveraineté parce que c'est vrai
monsieur péladeau
je pense à la confiance de tout le monde
sur sur ce plan là mais pour les
péquistes la social démocratie c'est
quelque chose qui est très important
dans leur esprit ça fait partie du
projet de faire un québec souverain oui
mais québec social démocrate est à cet
égard là j'ai peur que monsieur péladeau
échappe du monde en route et est par
ailleurs si pendant des mois et des mois
de tout le monde dit le pays le pays
c'est là qu'on s'en va ça va donner
lundi peu compliqué après le leadership
et à plus l'élection va approcher et
plus l'évidence d'un référendum va
s'éloigner d'expliquer à tout le monde
donc finalement ce qu'on a dit c'est
impossible c'est injuste pour le
leadership et qu'il y aura finalement
pas de référendum alors il ya dégagé
problème ici qui s'accumulent pour la
suite des choses
dilemme éternelle du pq c'est contenir
ce fameux référendum et c'est ce qui a
fait que la dernière élection a tourné
sur la question parce que c'est ce jour
on ne sait pas mais toi tu as raison tu
a charmé monsieur péladeau peut pas dire
en même temps moi tout ce qui m'est pas
se faire un pays après sao dia
répondrait ferrer dont on embête damien
eloi et ces mots là je rejoins michel
sur la social démocratie sauf que la
social démocratie
oui c'est très fort au pq wilzig roi
sauf que dans l'ensemble de la société
québécoise suis pas convaincu que que la
profession de foi est aussi forte
d'autant plus que dans un contexte de
rigueur économique qui est celui qu'on
connaît en ce moment des grands
principes de la social démocratie sont
beaucoup plus difficiles à l'avenir
eh bien je sens qu'on va en reparler de
ces débats au pq savez quand même aux
militants et aux québécois doit
peut-être quand même mieux
voir monsieur péladeau soit enquête du
genre d bah ouais merci beaucoup à vous
trois à la semaine prochaine